siete agentes de la policía peruana
murieron tras sufrir una emboscada
cuando patrullaban el centro poblado de
Natividad en la zona del Valle de los
ríos Apurímac n y mantaro conocido como
Brian al sur del Perú las autoridades
responsabilizan de este ataque a
presuntos terroristas que operan
protegiendo la producción de Coca el
área es conocido por ser la Cuenca
cocalera más grande del Perú los
policías fallecidos son los suboficiales
Alfredo Loaiza Luis cerrón wilder Eliseo
Iván Muñoz Sandro Villegas Williams
Quispe y juvenal coyahuacho la policía y
las fuerzas armadas realizan operativos
de búsqueda para capturar a los
responsables del atentado quienes
emplearon armas de fuego de largo
alcance según medios locales una columna
de sendero luminoso disparó al conductor
de la patrulla policial para
desestabilizar al vehículo y en paralelo
disparó a los agentes que se encontraban
en la parte posterior de la camioneta la
Policía Nacional del Perú y el
Ministerio del interior lamentaron la
muerte de los efectivos y enviaron
sentidas condolencias a los familiares
por su parte diversos congresistas
condenaron el asesinato y exigieron que
la justicia sancione enérgicamente a los
culpables